Amazon first hit the public markets in
June of 1997 as a humble online book
retailer but it didn't stay that way for
long they now control 40% of US
ecommerce 40% of the cloud computing
industry and they even operate a major
Hollywood production studio if you had
invested just a thousand dollars in
Amazon back in 1997 half investments
would have been worth 1.2 million
dollars in August of 2018 that's a
whopping a hundred and twenty thousand
percent profit in 21 years every
investor dreams of getting in on the
ground floor on a success story like
this but if buying low and selling high
is the touchdown most of the investment
world is filled with people fumbling the
ball left and right thankfully failure
is often the greatest teacher so let's
see what lessons we can learn from five
of the stranger fat investment crisis in
recent history
[Music]
it's 1993 and while I was doing the
running man de loop there it is the Thai
Thai company launched its newest
creation a deliberately under stuffed
toy animal called a beanie baby flash
the Orca and his eight original
compatriots showed up on shelves and
quickly found themselves in the midst of
beanie mania
there were beanie baby magazines and
scores of busted counterfeit rings one
couple even had to divvy up their beanie
baby stash before a judge as a part of
their divorce settlement
this particular craze is unique because
it was the result of a carefully crafted
strategy by the toy company itself Ty
Warner the eccentric billionaire owner
proved himself a master manipulator of
supply and demand he refused to sell
large orders to big-box stores instead
only selling small controlled amounts to
independent retailers new versions would
get retired only a few months later
prompting buyers to panic and rush the
stores but Warner knew the bubble
wouldn't last and in 1999 the company
promptly announced they were
discontinuing and will tie himself worn
out to the tune of a few billion many
adults who bought in lost their heads
and their wallets sometimes spending
thousands for a single toy bottom line
collectibles as an investment class are
extremely volatile only collect stuff
you truly love for its own sake style
guru Tim Gunn once called the crock shoe
a plastic hoof and why your fashionista
cousin might have wanted to light them
on fire investors got pretty fired up
when they started noticing some massive
numbers in September of 2006 the crocks
company IPO around $17 per share just 18
months later the stock had quadrupled to
more than $68 per share but that came
the Great Recession and shareholders
found themselves crying into their clogs
as the stock bottomed out at a dismal
dollar 21 a share and while it has
recovered somewhat since then thanks to
a very important British
learning Jorge it's never even come
close to its initial heights
so remember explosive growth while
exciting is more often than not a major
red flag unsustainability speaking of
explosive growth
a beloved regional donut chain called
Krispy Kreme decided in the late 90s to
go public and start expanding across the
nation under the ambitious CEO Scott
liven good the company went from just 95
stores in 11 states to 367 stores in 38
states in just two years the reported
net revenue skyrocketed by 442 percent
at one point the number of donuts they
made per week could stretch from New
York to LA Krispy Kreme artifacts were
even added to the Smithsonian Museum but
it wasn't long before cracks started to
show up in the icing it started with
some low earnings reports and in 2004 an
SEC audit accused the higher-ups of
channel stuffing that's when a company
forces unneeded product on stores to
inflate sales numbers after it was
revealed that their profit reports were
off by around 25 million dollars in the
wrong direction the stock lost around 80
percent of its value the CEO live and
good was promptly weeded so don't forget
competent leadership really matters and
if the numbers look too good to be true
there might not be any real dough
beneath the glaze funnily enough that
Krispy Kremes CEO famously blamed our
next entry for his company's demise in
1997 doctor Adkins new diet revolution
became a New York Times bestseller and
remained there for five years at the
height of its fame one in 11 American
adults reported themselves as following
a low-carb diet so it seemed to make
sense that Atkins nutritionals was
poised to profit big from their
proprietary line of low-carb snacks and
shakes but the famous founder died in
2003 following complications from a fall
probably didn't help when it came out
that he also had a history of congestive
heart failure and hypertension by the
mid-2000s the diet had run its course in
a 2005 they filed for chapter 11
bankruptcy after reporting a loss of 340
million dollars even
the company is still around it's become
something of a hot potato or sorry
meatball changing hands numerous times
apparently its current owner has been
trying to sell it since 2015 with no
takers even though the low-carb movement
is still around cyclical industries like
dieting are notoriously fickle and no
place to look for long-term returns
speaking of carbs let's look at a
healthier alternative an apple a day
keeps the doctor away right and in the
90s investors were hoping Mesa Snapple
brand would add a healthy boost to their
portfolios their wholesome feeling
branding combined with a funny
unorthodox spokeswoman nicknamed the
Snapple lady led to an all-out takeover
of the beverage market but when the
company went public most of the money
raised by the offering wasn't put to
work growing the business but rather
went to pay off debt and line the
pockets of their executives when the
Quaker Oats Company purchased Snapple to
the tune of 1.7 billion dollars in 1994
a lot of analysts considered it way
overpriced
and it turned out they were right it was
resold in 1997 for just 300 million
acquitting to a loss of roughly two
million dollars a day Snapple eventually
merged with dr. pepper and is trying
once again to capitalize on their
absurdist tumor but people read
ingredient labels now and it turns out
the best stuff on earth is basically as
a sugary as it's big soda counterparts
even the best branding on earth can only
float a company for so long TV and the
Internet are filled with people trying
to convince you to hop on bandwagon left
and right and while investing is a key
to growing wealth hopping from bad to
bad is fraught with danger even seasoned
experts get it wrong more often than not
so if you're not really the buy-and-hold
type
don't let FOMO get the best of you start
small commit to becoming a ruthless
researcher and strap in for a wild but
hopefully fun ride and that's our two
cents america from scratch is a PBS
Digital Studios show that asks what
might the u.s. be like if it was founded
to
it tackles big questions what if there
were no States should we lower the
voting age should we colonize Mars it's
like the best civics class ever
subscribe to America from scratch at the
link in the description below
have you ever invested in a fad or are
there some that we missed let us know in
the comments
[Music]